welcome to this webinar titled making
sense out of multiplex
when and how to use the visio farm
phenotyping tools
today we're going to cover a number of
things at a very high level
firstly a brief introduction to what is
phenotyping
how it can be useful
and when people do it
i'll then touch on some manual
approaches that can be taken in order to
do multiplex phenotyping
next i'll introduce the visio farm
approach which is an easy unbiased one
and then lastly we'll touch on some of
the ways your data can be explored
we're going to start with an
introduction to multiplex phenotyping
and ask what is phenotyping itself
phenotyping is simply the ability to
characterize individual cells
based upon the presence or the absence
of particular markers
in this cartoon example i've taken three
markers green magenta and blue which you
can see on the schematics of cells on
the left hand side
and in this case you can see that the
presence or absence of these three
markers
indicates that a cell is either cell
type a where it's solely represented by
the green marker
cell type b which is present for both
the green and the blue marker and cell
type c which is present for magenta and
blue
an important concept here is that not
only is it relevant whether or not a
marker is present but also that a marker
is absent
cell type c for instance may be
classified as a different marker if it's
a triple positive
now this schematic example may seem
trivial but you can actually directly
relate
cell types a b and c to relevant
biological phenotypes in this case the
green marker is cd4 the blue is cd8 and
the magenta could be fox b3 in this case
we have three different biologically
relevant phenotypes of t helper cells
regulatory t cells and activated
cytotoxic t cells
the question becomes how do we even
classify cells as being positive or
negative for an individual marker
and in this case
what we do is to simply look within
individual channels of our low high or
ultraplex phenotyping data
this is one example from a fluorescence
experiment and we're just showing the
dappy or nuclear marker and fox p3 in
blue and yellow respectively
in this case the first step is to define
our phenotypic unit
by identifying the individual cells
you can see in this case that we've
identified all of the different cells
some of which are positive and some of
which are negative
we can then use a simple threshold
classifier in order to identify cells
that are positive for any individual
marker in this case the fox b3
and separate these cells or subset them
at this point for instance counting the
number of cells looking at the distance
apart from each other or looking at
other characteristics
now this is fairly trivial with a single
marker but what about the example we had
before in this case three different
markers the green magenta and pink and
blue from the first example
if we extend this concept of a manual
approach to phenotyping
we can look at the same example with the
three markers
and what we can do is to start to build
up a decision tree for these simple t
cell markers
in this case first looking for instance
at cd4 and deciding is that positive or
is it negative
if we look at one example a triple
positive in this case it's quite a rare
phenotype but you can take a cd4
positive
cd8 positive and fox p3 positive cell
and we can form an activated double
positive t cell
so this is very simple for one example
but it's important to realize that even
with three markers
the decision tree becomes quite
complicated
in this case for three markers we have
seven choices and that can produce a
maximum of eight different phenotypes
you can see those listed over here on
the right and this decision tree can be
walked through for each different marker
to identify positivity or negativity in
this case
so hopefully you can appreciate even for
three markers this is quite complicated
you can imagine 4 6 7 10 15 20 or 30
markers that are becoming more and more
commonplace these sorts of decision
trees become rather ungainly
and this leads me to highlight the
problems or at least two of the problems
with manual phenotyping or this
threshold based approach
first as i mentioned it's not scalable
beyond a few channels
even with six or seven channels it
becomes very difficult to build a
decision tree to identify each of the
different phenotypes
the second problem which is quite an
issue in realistic or real world data is
that it forces the user to pick a
threshold intensity to define positivity
so in this case the user would have to
go through however many channels you
have and identify whether or not a cell
is positive or negative and define a
cutoff
there are many problems with this
approach not least of all that in real
tissue the level of background intensity
often changes the level of
autofluorescence or the noise profile
may also change and so picking a single
threshold simply does not provide robust
results
what visio farm have done to address
this problem or both of these problems
is actually create a multiplex
phenotyping tool that's fully integrated
into the visio farm platform
and this is an automated streamlined and
unbiased approach to multiplex
phenotyping
we can take a practically unlimited
number of channels to support all
modalities
and these include some of the things
i've mentioned before like
immunofluorescence
and imaging mass cytometry all within
the same platform
one of the key points of the visiopharm
software is that it's actually
acquisition agnostic
so in this case for instance no matter
where the data come from
everything from what we would call
single or dual pass immunofluorescence
that can have three to eight channels
cyclic immunofluorescent techniques
where markers are stained on tissue
imaged and then stripped and restained
for different probes
or imaging mass cytometry techniques
which are doing above 30 markers at a
time and continuing to increase the
number
all of these different modalities
despite being different file formats and
coming from different systems can all be
opened and analyzed using the viziopharm
platform
so let's take a look at how multiplex
phenotyping works in visiofarm
as with other modules we build up
workflows based on modular apps or units
and so the first app would be to do a
cell detection or a detection of
phenotypic units
and in this case we lean on our advanced
ai deep learning tools in order to do a
robust cell detection even in complex
tissue
to take just a second we always use ai
deep learning tools to do cell detection
chiefly because it can cope with the
wide variants that we often see
this could be variance in cell size cell
shape or cell intensity
it also provides a more robust solution
to highly clustered environments where
cells can be much more easily separated
moving on to the multiplex once we've
detected a cell outlines
we then simply use our easy to use
interface here so that the user can
detect which channels they would like to
include or exclude
from their clustering analysis
very often we would want to exclude
structural markers or
obviously the nuclear marker that was
used as a cell outline
but sometimes functional markers may
also want to be excluded from this
phenotypic step although they can always
be accessed later
so the users select which channels
they'd like to exclude
from the list of single or multiple
channels here and then simply trains the
classifier to automatically find the
represented classes in your training
data
some of the parameters here are tunable
if desired and i'll mention this in the
next couple of slides
but what the classifier will produce is
a list of all the represented phenotypes
that are found in the the sample data
i'd like to just jump into a little more
detail about what happens when the user
pushes this train button
all of what i'm about to show you
happens in the background but it's
important to understand how much of a
time saver it is in terms of defining
the positivity and negativity of cells
within a population
for this demonstration i'm going to go
back to my original example of a
three channel cd4 cd8 fox p3
markers
and here you can see a combination of
cells in our samples that we're going to
use for training
so when the user provides these cells
for training
and then hits that train button
the first step is to assess the range of
intensity in each channel
and what this basically means is to
first start for instance with the cd4
channel
and look for each individual cell that's
used for training
what's the positivity in the cd4 channel
this allows the software to then build
up an intensity distribution and an
understanding of the range of
intensities within the cd4 channel
this is then repeated for a second
channel in this case the fox p3
and again the intensity distribution is
built up into a model
lastly we can do the same for our cd8
channel and again build up an intensity
distribution
the second step of training once we
understand or have built a probabilistic
model about the positivity and
negativity in our sample is to report
the represented combinations
so in this case we go back not only to
look at
individual channels but to understand
what's happening on the whole cell level
so in this case
these intensity distributions are used
to build a machine learning model
and then we take each of the individual
cells in the training data set and then
feed it into this model
so in this case we're taking a fox p3
and a cd8 positive cell
running it against our machine learning
model and it will decide using a
probabilistic approach that this cell is
positive for fox p3 and cd8
there's one other filtering step to
remove very niche classes or classes
that are not highly represented and
again this is user tunable
but assuming this filtering step is
passed then a class is defined as a cd8
fox p3 positive cell
this is repeated again for other cells
in the sampling data set and in this
case for instance this cell is passed
through the machine learning protocol
filtered
and then a new class which is cd4 alone
is added to the list
this goes on and on through the sampling
data set and then eventually this class
list is reported to the end user
this is a really beneficial approach
because it saves the user time during
development and also builds a more
robust robust model against deciding
which cells are positive for which
different markers
i will just make one more point when it
comes to the training
is that you may have noticed these boxes
in one of the previous slides
when we're defining positivity or
negativity sometimes if we have
particularly complex data with abnormal
noise profiles for instance or
multi-modal
intensity distributions
we may wish to
refine the data before it's added into
the model
and in this case what the user can do is
provide either value ranges or quantile
ranges into the classifier
what this does is to take that intensity
distribution and actually limit it to a
certain part this for instance can cut
off low band noise or reduce problems
with bleed through from different
channels
and at this point only these data that
lie within the thresholds or within the
quantiles are used for characterization
so what i've covered in the last couple
of slides is how we go about training a
classifier once this is done at the
beginning of an experiment what we end
up having is an app that can be run
against more data either single images
or batch processed across a whole
dataset
and in this case you can see an app up
in the ribbon
for multiplex phenotyping
in order to run this back across the
image we simply take an image that has
had the cell outlines identified the
same as before
run that app from the ribbon
and what we get is each one of the
individual cell masks classified into
one of the identified phenotypes
at this point you can see that all of
the masks are color coded based on their
phenotypes for easy identification
and as i mentioned this process once the
classifier is trained can be run as part
of a workflow so for instance downstream
of artifact exclusion or tumor
identification
and can be run as part of a batch
process as well scaling it up to many
hundreds of images
so i'd like to take the last part of
this this talk to talk about exploring
your data
once we have classified this individual
image to identify all the different
phenotypic classes within it and have
produced these overlay masks there are
lots of different things that we can do
with this data set
for instance
we can produce semi-quantitative or
qualitative heat maps
these are great for identifying hot
spots of particular phenotypes or
combinations of phenotypes
i say semi-quantitative because we can
also take these heat maps and use them
to define regions of interest for
instance identifying the hot spots of
cd68 macrophage markers t-cell markers
or any combination and then further
identifying or analyzing these areas
counting for instance other cell types
secondarily we have a wide range of
outputs and quantitative outputs
available in visiofarm so almost any
parameter can be measured and reported
on a per cell level
as a granular output to be able to
identify for instance cell size cell
shape the intensity distribution in that
particular class or even spatial
measurements such as the object distance
between any two classes for instance t
cells and macrophages or any classes and
any structure if you're interested in
looking at
immune cell infiltration or the distance
to blood vessels or the distance to
tumor boundaries
all of these can be reported at a very
granular level as well
i also want to mention that built into
the vizio farm software we can produce a
number of different phenographic outputs
i'm going to touch on these in the next
slide
the first is the phenotypic profile
and what this allows you to do is to
take the output of a multiplex
phenotyping analysis and then plot the
prevalence of each of the different
classes you see across multiple regions
of interest or multiple images
for instance if you're trying to discern
responders versus non-responders or
immune activation in different areas
this is a very nice way to quickly be
able to identify particular images or
particular rois that have a response
the second phenograph we can produce are
a number of different plots such as the
disney plot
in this case this clusters similar
objects as nearby points and dissimilar
objects as distant points
i'll also mention at this point that the
colors in the disney plot you see here
in the background are also directly
related to the colors in the overlays
that i showed in the last slide so it's
very easy to take a particular class and
identify the cell types back in the
original image
not only can we produce the type plot as
you see in the background but the per
channel heat maps as well to identify
the contributions of particular types of
cells
another plot we can create is what we
call the phenotypic matrix
in this case this is very useful for
probing the composition of individual
phenotypic classes
a good example for instance is if you
have activated t cells that are positive
for cd8 and then granzyme b
to make them cytotoxic
in this case we may want to see in
different conditions
which cells are more positive or which
images show more positivity in the
granzyme b class than other ones again
the matrix allows you to probe these
sorts of questions
the last phenotypic plot i'd like to
mention today is the neighborhood
analysis
and what this allows you to do again
very easily at the push of a button is
to run a statistical analysis or a
statistical spatial analysis
to indicate whether or not the
interactions between two different
phenotypes are pretty much by chance or
if they're more likely than you would
expect if all of the different cells
were distributed randomly
this is great for identifying particular
cell populations and whether or not
they're associating with each other or
being actively excluding from each other
very important in things like antigen
presenting cells that rely on cell cell
interactions
as i briefly mentioned all of these
phenographs are available from the
ribbon at the top of the viziofarm
software it requires no coding or no
scripting in order to produce any of
these plots or run any of the analysis
i've spoken about today so it's a really
easy way for new users to be able to do
quite complex exploratory analysis
without much training and without much
need to to get to know new features of
the software
the other important key with the vizio
farm software is that your data are
always accessible to you
so for instance if you run a clustering
analysis or a phenotypic analysis you
can always export any of the data the
cell positions the intensities the
classification size shape texture
parameters all of these data can be
easily exported for single images or
whole data sets into simple text files
such as tab separated value lists
but we can also export the overlays that
are produced so for instance if you
wanted to do a custom visualization we
can always export the overlays as tiff
files or if you prefer vectors xml
just to summarize briefly what we've
covered today
the visiopharm multiplex phenotyping is
an easy to use easy to configure
unbiased multiplex clustering tool
we've taken incredible complexity here
and made it very simple to use and no
step do you require any programming
learning new syntactic languages or
coding
we're also format agnostic so everything
i've shown you today can be applied to
almost any data type be it imaging mass
cytometry fluorescence or other
techniques
importantly multiplex phenotyping
invisiofarm integrates with existing
tools this means you can leverage the
power of our ai deep learning both for
cell detection but also as i briefly
mentioned identifying areas of interest
excluding artifacts or necrotic areas or
any other upstream tool that could
benefit from ai deep learning
and lastly the outputs are fully
customizable you really do get to decide
what questions you ask of your data
this could be quantitative measures as i
mentioned as summary statistics or
granular per cell data
density heat maps are very easy to
produce and to use
or are built built-in phenotyping plots
including disney's and neighborhood
analysis
i'd like to thank you for watching this
webinar today
i hope you've gained some valuable
insights into multiplexing and how the
vizio farm platform approaches these
sorts of analyses